Eh bien, comme Chris l'a souligné, j'étudie le cerveau humain --
les fonctions et la structure du cerveau humain.
Et je voudrais que vous réfléchissiez un instant à ce que cela implique.
Voici cette masse de gelée - 1,4 kilos de gelée
que vous pouvez tenir dans la paume de votre main
et elle peut contempler l'immensité de l'espace interstellaire.
Elle peut contempler le sens de l'infini
et elle peut se contempler elle-même, contemplant le sens de l'infini.
Et c'est cette propriété récursive particulière, qu'on appelle la conscience de soi,
qui est, je pense, le Saint Graal des neurosciences, de la neurologie,
et on espère, un jour, comprendre comment cela se produit.
OK. Alors comment étudier ce mystérieux organe ?
Vous avez là 100 milliards de cellules nerveuses,
des petites branches de protoplasme qui interagissent entre elles,
et de cette activité émerge l'éventail complet des capacités
qu'on appelle la nature et la conscience humaine.
Comment çà marche ?
Eh bien, il existe de nombreuses manières d'étudier les fonctions du cerveau humain.
L'une de ces approches, la plus en usage,
est d'observer des patients dont une petite partie du cerveau est endommagée de façon permanente,
où il s'est produit une modification génétique.
Dans ces cas-là, nous n'assistons pas à une détérioration généralisée
de toutes vos capacités mentales,
une sorte d'affaissement de vos capacités cognitives.
Nous assistons plutôt à la perte très spécifique d'une fonction,
les autres fonctions demeurant intactes,
et çà nous permet d'affirmer avec une certaine confiance
que cette partie du cerveau est en quelque façon impliquée dans la médiation de cette fonction.
On peut donc projeter la fonction sur la structure
et ainsi découvrir comment les circuits s'y prennent
pour produire cette fonction.
C'est ce que nous essayons de faire.
Laissez-moi vous donner quelques exemples frappants de ceci.
En fait, je vais vous donner trois exemples de six minutes chaque durant cette conférence.
Le premier exemple est un syndrome peu ordinaire, nommé le syndrome de Capgras.
Si vous regardez la première diapositive,
ceci est le lobe temporal, le lobe frontal et le lobe pariétal, OK --
les lobes qui constituent le cerveau.
Et si vous regardez, enfouie sous la surface interne des lobes temporaux --
vous ne pouvez la voir ici --
il y a une petite structure nommée la circonvolution fusiforme.
On l'a appelée « la zone des visages » dans le cerveau
parce que lorsque qu'elle est endommagée, vous ne pouvez plus reconnaître le visage des gens.
Vous pouvez toujours les reconnaître à leur voix
et dire « ah oui, c'est Joe »,
mais vous ne pouvez plus les reconnaître en regardant leur visage, d'accord ?
Vous ne pouvez même plus vous reconnaître vous-mêmes à travers le miroir.
En fait, vous savez qu'il s'agit de vous, car lorsque vous faites un clin d'oeil, ça vous fait un clin d'oeil,
et vous savez qu'il s'agit d'un miroir,
mais vous ne pouvez pas vraiment vous reconnaître comme vous-mêmes.
OK. Aujourd'hui ce syndrome est réputé être causé par une lésion de la circonvolution fusiforme.
Mais il existe un autre syndrome très rare, si rare, en fait,
que très peu de médecins en ont entendu parler, même parmi les neurologues.
Nous l'appelons l'illusion des sosies de Capgras.
C'est le cas où un patient, par ailleurs parfaitement normal,
ayant eu une blessure à la tête, s'éveille d'un coma.
Tout semble normal. Il regarde sa mère
et dit : « Cette femme ressemble à s'y méprendre à ma mère,
mais c'est un imposteur --
c'est une autre femme qui prétend être ma mère. »
Maintenant, pourquoi cela se produit ?
Pourquoi un individu -- et cette personne est parfaitement lucide et intelligente
par ailleurs, mais lorsqu'il voit sa mère,
cette illusion se manifeste et il dit « ce n'est pas ma mère ».
Maintenant, l'interprétation la plus courante de ceci,
que vous trouverez dans tous les livres de psychiatrie,
est l'explication freudienne, qui consiste à dire que ce type --
et le même argument s'applique aux femmes, soit dit en passant,
mais je ne parlerai que des hommes --
lorsque vous êtes un bébé, un nourrisson,
vous éprouvez une forte attraction sexuelle envers votre mère.
C'est le complexe d'Oedipe de Freud.
Je ne dis pas que j'y crois,
mais il s'agit de la conception freudienne traditionnelle.
Et alors, lorsque vous grandissez, le cortex se développe,
et inhibe ces pulsions sexuelles latentes envers votre mère.
Dieu merci, sans quoi vous seriez tous excités sexuellement en voyant votre mère.
Et alors ce qui se passe c'est que,
vous recevez un coup à la tête, qui endommage le cortex,
ce qui permet à toutes ces pulsions sexuelles latentes d'émerger,
jaillissant à la surface, et soudain, de manière inexplicable,
vous vous retrouvez sexuellement excité par votre mère.
Alors vous vous dites « Mon Dieu, si c'est bien ma mère,
comment se fait-il que je sois excité ?
C'est une autre femme. C'est un imposteur. »
C'est la seule interprétation qui ait un sens pour votre cerveau endommagé.
Ça ne m'a jamais vraiment persuadé, cet argument.
C'est très ingénieux, comme tous les arguments freudiens...
(Rires)
... mais ça ne m'a pas convaincu parce que j'ai vu
un patient avoir la même illusion envers son caniche.
(Rires)
Il disait : « Docteur, ce n'est pas Fifi, il est exactement comme Fifi,
mais c'est un autre chien. » Vous voyez ?
Maintenant, essayez d'utiliser la théorie freudienne ici.
(Rires)
Vous commencerez à parler de bestialité latente chez tous les humains,
ou quelque chose comme ça, ce qui est plutôt absurde, bien sûr.
Alors, que se passe-t-il vraiment?
Pour expliquer cet étrange dysfonctionnement,
on observe la structure et les fonctions des circuits normaux de la vision à l'intérieur du cerveau.
En temps normal, les signaux visuels entrent par les globes oculaires,
et rejoignent les zones de la vision dans le cerveau.
Il existe en réalité 30 zones à l'arrière de votre cerveau qui s'occupent uniquement de la vision,
et après avoir traité cette information, le message est transmis à une petite structure
appelée la circonvolution fusiforme, là où vous percevez les visages.
Les neurones qui s'y trouvent sont sensibles aux visages.
Vous pouvez donc l'appeler « la zone des visages du cerveau », d'accord ?
J'en ai parlé précédemment.
Lorsque cette zone est endommagée, vous perdez la capacité de percevoir les visages.
Mais depuis cette zone, le message est transmis
à une structure appelée l'amygdale, dans le système limbique,
le centre des émotions dans le cerveau,
et cette structure, l'amygdale,
évalue l'importance émotionnelle de ce que vous observez.
Est-ce une proie ? Un prédateur ? Un partenaire ?
Ou bien est-ce quelque chose de tout à fait banal, comme un bout de tissu,
ou un morceau de craie, ou bien... je ne veux pas désigner ceci mais...
ou une chaussure, ou quelque chose comme ça ? D'accord ?
Que vous pouvez ignorer complètement.
Donc, si l'amygdale est activée, et qu'il s'agit d'une chose importante,
les messages sont transmis au système nerveux autonome.
Votre coeur se met à battre plus rapidement,
vous commencez à suer, afin de dissiper la chaleur que vous allez
générer du fait de l'activité musculaire.
Et c'est une chance, parce qu'on peut placer deux électrodes sur votre paume
et mesurer les variations de tonus de la peau produites par la sueur.
Je peux donc déterminer, lorsque vous observez un objet,
si vous êtes agité, ou alors, si vous êtes excité ou pas, d'accord ?
J'y reviendrai dans une minute.
Mon idée était que lorsque ce type regarde un objet, lorsqu'il regarde sa --
en fait, n'importe quel objet, c'est transmis aux zones de la vision et --
peu importe, c'est traité dans la circonvolution fusiforme,
et vous pouvez reconnaître qu'il s'agit d'une plante, ou d'une table
ou de votre mère, d'accord ?
Ensuite le message déboule dans l'amygdale,
et descend le long du système nerveux autonome.
Mais peut-être que chez ce type, la connexion qui va de l'amygdale au système limbique --
le centre émotionnel du cerveau -- est coupée par l'accident.
Donc, parce que le fusiforme est intact,
le type peut toujours reconnaître sa mère,
et dire, « Ah oui, elle ressemble à ma mère. »
Mais, parce que la connexion aux centres émotionnels est rompue,
il se dit, « Mais comment se peut-il que je ne ressente aucun réconfort s'il s'agit de ma mère? »
Ou bien de la terreur, comme cela est toujours possible. D'accord ?
(Rires)
Et donc, il se dit : « Comment expliquer cette inconcevable absence d'émotions ?
Ça ne peut pas être ma mère.
C'est une femme étrange qui prétend être ma mère. »
Comment tester cela ?
Eh bien, si on prend n'importe lequel d'entre vous, on vous place devant un écran,
et on mesure la réaction galvanique de votre peau,
et en projetant des images sur l'écran,
je peux déterminer votre taux d'exsudation lorsque vous voyez un objet,
comme une table ou un parapluie -- bien sûr, vous ne suez pas.
Si je vous montre une image d'un lion ou d'un tigre, ou d'une pin-up, vous vous mettez à suer, d'accord ?
Et, croyez-le ou non, si je vous montre une image de votre mère...
Je parle des gens normaux -- vous vous mettez à suer.
Et vous n'avez même pas besoin d'être Juif.
(Rires)
Maintenant, qu'arrive-t-il -- qu'arrive-t-il si vous montrez ces images à ce patient ?
Vous placez le patient devant l'écran, vous lui montrez les images
et vous mesurez la réaction galvanique de sa peau.
Pour les tables, les chaises, le chiffon, aucune réaction, comme chez les gens normaux,
mais lorsque vous lui montrez l'image de sa mère,
la réaction galvanique de sa peau est nulle.
Il n'y a aucune réaction émotionnelle vis-à-vis de sa mère
parce que la connexion qui relie les zones de la vision aux centres émotionnels est rompue.
Les zones de la vision étant normales, la vision est normale,
ses émotions sont normales -- il peut rire, pleurer, ainsi de suite --
mais la connexion qui relie la vision aux émotions est rompue,
et, par conséquent, il a l'illusion que sa mère est un imposteur.
C'est un charmant exemple du type de travail que nous menons,
nous choisissons un syndrome psychiatrique nerveux bizarre, apparemment incompréhensible,
nous affirmons que l'explication freudienne traditionnelle est erronée,
qu'il est possible de fournir une explication précise
sur la base de nos connaissances de l'anatomie neuronale du cerveau.
Soit dit en passant, si la mère de ce patient
l'appelle depuis une chambre adjacente
et qu'il décroche, alors sa réaction est « Oh ! Maman, comment vas-tu ? Où es-tu ? »
L'illusion ne se manifeste pas au téléphone.
Si elle revient le voir après une heure, il dira « Qui êtes-vous ?
Vous ressemblez à ma mère. » D'accord ?
La raison est qu'il existe un chemin distinct
reliant les centres auditifs aux centres émotifs dans le cerveau,
et qui n'est pas rompu par l'accident.
C'est donc pourquoi il peut reconnaître sa mère au téléphone sans problème.
Mais lorsqu'il la voit en personne, il dit qu'elle est un imposteur.
Bon. Comment tout cet ensemble de circuits est-il organisé dans le cerveau ?
Est-ce naturel, génétique, ou bien est-ce culturel ?
Et on approche ce problème
en considérant un autre syndrome curieux, appelé le membre fantôme.
Et vous savez tous ce qu'est un membre fantôme.
Lorsqu'un bras ou une jambe est amputée, en cas de gangrène,
ou lorsque vous la perdez à la guerre, par exemple la guerre d'Irak --
c'est un problème sérieux actuellement --
vous continuez à ressentir vivement la présence de ce bras manquant,
et çà s'appelle un bras fantôme ou une jambe fantôme.
En fait, on peut avoir un fantôme avec presque n'importe quelle partie du corps.
Croyez-le ou non, même avec les viscères.
J'ai eu des patientes dont l'utérus avait été retiré -- par hystérectomie --
qui avaient un utérus fantôme, incluant les crampes menstruelles
au moment habituel durant le mois.
Du coup, un étudiant m'a demandé, l'autre jour,
« ont-elles des règles fantômes ? »
(Rires)
Un sujet mûr pour l'investigation scientifique, mais que nous n'avons pas entrepris.
Bon, alors la question est :
que peut-on apprendre sur les membres fantômes en réalisant des expériences ?
Une des choses qu'on a découverte
est que la moitié des patients qui ont des membres fantômes
prétendent qu'ils peuvent bouger leur membre.
Il pourra donner une tape sur l'épaule de son frère,
Il pourra répondre au téléphone, saluer.
Ce sont des sensations très vives, très convaincantes.
Le patient n'est pas délirant.
Il sait que le bras n'est pas là
mais, malgré cela, il s'agit pour lui d'une expérience sensorielle très convaincante.
Toutefois, chez l'autre moitié des patients, cela n'arrive pas.
Le membre fantôme -- ils diront : « Mais, docteur, le membre fantôme est paralysé.
il est coincé dans un spasme de serrement et cela est atrocement douloureux.
Si seulement je pouvais le bouger, peut-être la douleur s'en irait. »
Maintenant, pourquoi un membre fantôme serait-il paralysé ?
Cela ressemble à un oxymore.
Mais lorsque on a étudié leur dossier, on a découvert
que chez les gens dont le membre fantôme était paralysé,
le véritable bras était lui-même paralysé suite à une lésion du nerf périphérique.
Le nerf activant le bras a été coupé,
sectionné par un accident de moto, par exemple.
Donc, le patient avait conservé son bras, qui le faisait souffrir,
dans un plâtre pour quelques mois, ou un an, et alors
dans une tentative malavisée de le départir de sa douleur,
le chirurgien lui ampute le bras,
et alors il se retrouve avec un bras fantôme et les mêmes douleurs, d'accord ?
Et ceci est un problème clinique très sérieux.
Les patients font une dépression.
Certains sont conduits au suicide, d'accord ?
Comment traiter ce syndrome ?
Comment se retrouve-t-on avec un membre fantôme paralysé ?
Lorsque j'ai examiné les dossiers, j'ai découvert qu'ils avaient conservé leur bras,
et que les nerfs qui activent le bras avaient été coupés,
et le bras s'est retrouvé paralysé,
et demeuré dans un plâtre plusieurs mois avant l'amputation,
et que cette douleur avait été transférée dans le membre fantôme.
Comment cela arrive-t-il ?
Lorsque le bras était intact, mais paralysé,
le cerveau envoyait des commandes au bras, la partie frontale du cerveau disant « bouge, »
le feedback visuel répondant « non. »
Bouge. Non. Bouge. Non. Bouge. Non.
Et ce conflit s'est inscrit dans la structure même des circuits du cerveau.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la paralysie acquise, d'accord ?
Le cerveau apprend, à cause de ce lien associatif de Hebb,
que la simple commande de bouger le bras
crée la sensation d'un bras paralysé,
et alors, lorsque le bras a été amputé,
cette paralysie acquise a été transférée dans le -- dans votre image corporelle
et dans votre membre fantôme, d'accord ?
Maintenant, comment aider ces patients ?
Comment désapprendre la paralysie acquise
de telle sorte que vous pouvez soulager le bras fantôme
de ce spasme atrocement douloureux ?
Eh bien, on s'est dit, que se passerait-il si on envoyait la commande au membre fantôme,
et qu'on donne au cerveau le feedback visuel qu'il obéit à la commande, d'accord ?
Peut-être qu'on pourrait soulager la douleur fantôme, la crampe fantôme.
Comment faire çà ? Eh bien, il y a la réalité virtuelle.
Mais cela coûte des milliards de dollars.
Alors j'ai réussi à faire la même chose pour trois dollars,
mais n'allez pas le dire à mes agences de financement.
(Rires)
On fabrique ce que j'appelle une boite miroir.
C'est une boite de carton avec un miroir au milieu,
et alors on place le fantôme -- donc mon premier patient, Derek, vient me voir.
Son bras a été amputé il y a 10 ans.
Il a eu une avulsion brachiale, les nerfs ont été sectionnés
et le bras était paralysé, puis demeuré dans un plâtre une année, et ensuite amputé.
Il a eu un membre fantôme, atrocement douloureux, et il ne pouvait pas le bouger.
C'était un membre fantôme paralysé.
Alors il est venu me voir, et je lui ai donné un miroir comme ça, dans une boite,
que j'appelle une boite miroir, d'accord ?
Et le patient a mis son bras fantôme, le gauche,
enserré dans un spasme, du côté gauche du miroir,
et la main normale du côté droit du miroir,
et prend la même posture, sa main serrée,
et regarde dans le miroir, et que ressent-il ?
Il voit son fantôme ressuscité,
parce qu'il voit la réflexion de son bras normal à travers le miroir,
et il lui semble que son bras est ressuscité.
J'ai dit: « Maintenant regarde, agite ton fantôme --
plutôt tes vrais doigts, ou bouge tes doigts en regardant à travers le miroir. »
Il aura l'impression visuelle que son fantôme bouge, n'est-ce pas ?
C'est évident, mais la chose étonnante est que
le patient se met à dire, « Oh mon Dieu, mon fantôme bouge à nouveau,
et la douleur, le spasme de serrement, est disparu. »
Et souvenez-vous, le premier patient qui est venu me voir --
(Applaudissements)
-- merci. (Applaudissements)
Mon premier patient est venu me voir, il a regardé à travers le miroir
et je lui ai dit « observe la réflexion de ton membre fantôme. »
Il s'est mis à ricaner, et il a dit « je peux voir mon membre fantôme. »
Mais il n'est pas stupide. Il sait que ce n'est pas réel.
Il sait qu'il s'agit d'une réflexion,
mais il a une expérience sensorielle très vive.
Alors, je lui ai dit : « fais bouger ta main normale et ton fantôme. »
Et il a dit « Oh, je ne peux pas bouger mon fantôme. Vous le savez. C'est douloureux. »
Je lui ai dit « bouge ta main normale. »
Et il a dit « Oh mon Dieu, mon fantôme bouge de nouveau, je ne peux pas le croire !
Et ma douleur s'en est allée. » D'accord ?
Et alors je lui ai dit « Ferme les yeux. »
Il a fermé les yeux.
« Bouge ta main normale. »
« Oh, rien -- c'est à nouveau serré. »
« OK, ouvre les yeux. »
« Oh mon Dieu, oh mon Dieu, il bouge de nouveau ! »
Il était comme un gamin dans un magasin de bonbons.
Alors j'ai dit, OK, ceci prouve ma théorie à propos de la paralysie acquise.
et le rôle critique de l'input visuel.
mais je n'obtiendrai pas un Prix Nobel
pour avoir aidé une personne à bouger son membre fantôme.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
C'est une capacité complètement inutile, si vous y pensez bien.
(Rires)
Mais j'ai alors commencé à comprendre qu'il y avait peut-être d'autres formes de paralysies
que l'on voit en neurologie, comme l'accident cérébrovasculaire, la dystonie focale --
il pourrait y avoir un composante acquise à cela
que l'on pourrait renverser à l'aide d'un simple miroir.
Alors j'ai dit : « Écoute, Derek » --
premièrement, le gars ne peut pas se balader comme ça, avec un miroir, pour alléger sa douleur --
J'ai dit, « Écoute, Derek, apporte-le à la maison et utilise-le une semaine ou deux.
Peut-être qu'avec de la pratique,
tu pourras te passer du miroir, désapprendre la paralysie
et bouger ton bras paralysé
pour soulager toi-même la douleur. »
Il a dit OK et l'a emmené chez lui.
J'ai dit, « Écoute, ça coûte deux dollars après tout. Emmène-le chez toi. »
Alors il l'a apporté chez lui, et après deux semaines, il m'a téléphoné,
me disant, « Docteur, vous n'allez pas le croire. »
J'ai dit, « Quoi ? »
Il a dit, « C'est parti. »
J'ai dit, « Qu'est-ce qui est parti ? »
J'ai pensé que peut-être la boite était partie.
(Rires)
Il a dit, « Non, non, non, vous savez, ce fantôme que j'ai eu depuis 10 ans ?
Il a disparu. »
J'ai alors dit -- je me suis inquiété, j'ai pensé, mon Dieu,
j'ai changé l'image corporelle de ce gars,
qu'en est-il des sujets humains, de l'éthique, et tout çà ?
Alors j'ai dit, « Derek, çà te pose un problème ? »
Il a dit « Non, les trois derniers jours, je n'ai pas eu de bras fantôme
donc pas de douleur fantôme à l'épaule, pas de serrement,
pas de douleur fantôme de l'avant-bras, toutes ces douleurs sont parties.
Mais le problème c'est que mes doigts fantômes pendillent encore de l'épaule,
et votre boite ne les atteint pas. »
(Rires)
« pouvez-vous changer le modèle et le placer sur mon front
de sorte que je puisse, vous savez, faire cela et éliminer mes doigts fantômes ? »
Il a cru que j'étais une sorte de magicien.
Maintenant, pourquoi çà marche ?
C'est parce que le cerveau se trouve aux prises avec un énorme conflit sensoriel.
Il reçoit des messages de la vision disant que le fantôme est de retour.
D'autre part, la réception adéquate ne se produit pas,
les signaux musculaires disant qu'il n'y a pas de bras, d'accord ?
Votre centre moteur dit au contraire qu'il y a bien un bras,
et en raison de ce conflit, le cerveau dit, au diable tout ceci,
il n'y a pas de fantôme, il n'y a pas de bras, d'accord ?
il affecte une sorte de déni -- il nie les signaux.
Et lorsque le bras disparaît, le bonus c'est que la douleur disparaît
parce qu'il est impossible de ressentir une douleur incorporelle, flottant là, dans l'espace.
Donc, c'est le bonus.
Maintenant, cette technique a été testée chez des dizaines de patients
par d'autres groupes à Helsinki,
il se pourrait qu'il s'avère être une traitement efficace de la douleur fantôme,
et, en effet, des gens l'ont essayé pour la réhabilitation en cas d'accident cérébrovasculaire.
Une attaque cérébrale, vous songez normalement
à une lésion des fibres, rien à faire.
Il s'avère cependant qu'une certaine composante de la paralysie soit aussi acquise,
et que peut-être cette composante peut être contournée en utilisant des miroirs.
Ceci a également été l'objet d'essais cliniques,
et a aidé un grand nombre de patients.
OK, laissez-moi passer à la troisième partie de mon exposé,
qui porte sur un autre curieux phénomène appelé la synesthésie.
Elle a été découverte par Francis Galton au 19e siècle.
C'était un cousin de Charles Darwin.
Il a remarqué que certaines personnes dans la population
qui sont par ailleurs parfaitement normales, avaient la particularité suivante --
chaque fois qu'elles voient un chiffre, il est coloré.
Cinq est bleu, sept est jaune, huit est chartreuse,
et neuf, indigo, OK ?
Rappelez-vous: ces personnes sont absolument normales d'autre part.
Ou bien do dièse. Parfois les tons évoquent des couleurs.
Do dièse est bleu, fa dièse est vert,
et un autre ton peut être jaune, d'accord ?
Pourquoi cela se produit-il ?
Cela s'appelle la synesthésie -- Galton l'a nommé la synesthésie,
c'est-à-dire un entrecroisement des sens.
Pour nous, tous les sens sont distincts.
Mais ces gens les emmêlent.
Pourquoi cela arrive-t-il ?
Il y a un ou deux aspects de ce problème qui sont vraiment intriguants.
La synesthésie est un trait de parenté,
Galton en a donc déduit qu'elle avait une origine héréditaire, génétique.
Deuxièmement, la synesthésie -- et cela m'amène
au thème principal de cette conférence, qui porte sur la créativité --
la synesthésie est huit fois plus fréquente chez les artistes, les poètes, les écrivains
et autres créateurs, que dans la population en général.
Pourquoi çà ?
Je vais proposer une réponse.
Personne n'y a jamais répondu.
OK, qu'est-ce que la synesthésie ? Qu'elle en est la cause ?
Eh bien, il y a plusieurs théories.
L'une d'elles prétend qu'ils sont tout simplement fous.
Mais, ce n'est pas vraiment une théorie scientifique, alors nous allons la laisser tomber.
Une autre théorie dit que ce sont des drogués adeptes de LSD et de marijuana, d'accord ?
Bon, il pourrait y avoir un fond de vérité à ceci
parce que c'est beaucoup plus commun ici, dans la Bay Area, qu'à San Diego.
(Rires)
OK. La troisième théorie dit que --
bon, demandons-nous qu'est-ce qui se passe réellement dans la synesthésie ? D'accord ?
Donc, on a découvert que la zone des couleurs et la zone des chiffres
sont voisines l'une de l'autre dans le cerveau, dans la circonvolution fusiforme.
On a donc pensé qu'il pourrait y avoir des interconnexions accidentelles
entre les couleurs et les chiffres dans le cerveau.
De sorte que chaque fois que vous voyez un chiffre, vous percevez une couleur correspondante,
et c'est pourquoi il y a synesthésie.
Maintenant rappelez-vous -- pourquoi cela arrive-t-il ?
Pourquoi y aurait-il des interconnexions chez certaines personnes ?
Vous vous rappelez que j'ai dit qu'il s'agissait d'un trait de famille ?
Ceci vous donne un indice
Et c'est qu'il y a un gène anormal,
une mutation dans le gène, qui entraîne cette interconnexion anormale.
En fait, à la naissance,
tout est connecté à tout le reste.
De sorte que chaque zone du cerveau est connectée à toutes les autres zones,
et ces connexions sont graduellement élaguées afin de créer
l'architecture modulaire caractéristique du cerveau adulte.
Donc, s'il y a un gène qui cause cet élagage,
et qu'il s'y produit une mutation,
vous obtenez un élagage insuffisant entre des parties adjacentes dans le cerveau,
et si çà se produit entre les chiffres et les couleurs, vous obtenez une synesthésie couleur-chiffre.
Si c'est entre les tons et les couleurs, une synesthésie ton-couleur.
Jusqu'ici, tout va bien.
Maintenant, qu'arrive-t-il si ce gène est exprimé dans tout le cerveau,
de sorte que toutes ses parties sont reliées entre elles ?
Pensez à ce que tous les artistes, écrivains et poètes, ont en commun,
la capacité d'apprivoiser la pensée métaphorique,
de relier des idées sans lien apparent,
comme « ceci est l'Est, et Juliette est le Soleil. »
Bon, vous ne vous dites pas "Juliette est le soleil --
est-ce que çà signifie qu'elle est une boule de feu incandescente ?"
Les schizophrènes le font, mais c'est une toute autre histoire, d'accord ?
Les gens normaux disent qu'elle est chaleureuse comme le soleil,
qu'elle est radieuse comme le soleil, nourricière comme le soleil.
Ils trouvent les liens immédiatement.
Maintenant, si on suppose que cette plus grande inter-connectivité
et ces concepts se trouvent aussi dans différentes parties du cerveau,
alors çà va créer une plus grande propension
à la créativité et à la pensée métaphorique
chez les personnes synesthésiques.
Et, par conséquent, une fréquence huit fois plus importante de la synesthésie
parmi les poètes, les artistes et les écrivains.
OK -- c'est une conception très phrénologique de la synesthésie.
La dernière démonstration -- puis-je prendre une autre minute ?
(Applaudissements)
OK. Je vais vous démontrer que vous êtes tous synesthètes, mais que vous le niez.
Voici ce que j'appelle l'alphabet Martien, tout comme notre alphabet,
A est A, B est B, C est C,
différentes formes pour différents phonèmes, d'accord ?
Voici donc l'alphabet Martien.
Une lettre est Kiki, l'autre est Buba.
Laquelle est Kiki et laquelle est Buba ?
Combien parmi vous pensez que ceci est Kiki et ceci Buba ? Levez votre main.
Bon, on a un ou deux mutants...
(Rires)
Combien parmi vous pensez que ceci est Buba et ceci Kiki ? Levez votre main.
99 pour cent d'entre vous.
Mais bon, personne ici n'est Martien, comment avez-vous fait çà ?
C'est parce que vous construisez tous un modèle transversal -- une abstraction synesthétique --
c'est-à-dire que cette inflexion anguleuse, « Kiki »,
dans votre cortex auditif, les cellules ciliées étant excitées, « Kiki »,
imitent l'inflexion visuelle -- subite -- de cette forme dentelée.
Et c'est très important, parce que çà nous apprend
que notre cerveau entreprend une forme primitive de --
C'est simplement que -- ça ressemble à une illusion idiote
mais les photons dans votre oeil prennent cette forme,
et les cellules ciliées dans votre oreille excitent le schéma auditif,
mais le cerveau est en mesure d'extraire le dénominateur commun.
C'est une forme primitive d'abstraction,
et on sait maintenant que çà se passe dans la circonvolution fusiforme
parce que lorsqu'elle est endommagée,
les gens perdent la capacité d'établir des associations de type Buba Kiki
et perdent également la capacité de concevoir des métaphores.
Si vous lui demandez ce que veut dire l'expression
« tout ce qui brille n'est pas d'or ? »
Le patient répond, « Eh bien, si c'est métallique et brillant, ça ne veut pas dire que c'est de l'or. »
« Vous devez mesurer sa masse volumique », OK ?
Ils perdent complètement de vue le sens métaphorique.
Cette section est huit fois plus grosse chez les primates supérieurs --
en particulier chez les humains -- que chez les primates inférieurs.
Quelque chose de très intéressant se produit là dans la circonvolution angulaire
car c'est le carrefour de l'ouïe, de la vision et du toucher,
et elle est devenue énorme chez les humains -- et quelque chose de très intéressant s'y produit.
Je crois qu'elle constitue la base de nombreuses capacités humaines uniques
comme l'abstraction, la métaphore et la créativité.
Toutes ces questions que les philosophes ont étudiées depuis des millénaires,
nous, les scientifiques, nous pouvons commencer à les explorer en faisant de l'imagerie du cerveau
et en étudiant des patients et en posant les bonnes questions.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
(Désolé)
(Rires)